gérard bayssière bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
peut-on parler d'une crise sans
précédent a tout à fait parce que là il
ya une baisse de la demande mondiale à
qui vient du 1er secteur du marché de la
demande du pétrole qui est le marché du
transport
or le confinement une grande partie de
la population du globe
amen effectivement la suppression des
déplacements automobiles et camions la
suppression des déplacements aériens et
une forte réduction de la des
déplacements et de la navigation
maritime donc le premier secteur
d'emploi du pétrole est très sévèrement
touché a certainement autour de 20
millions de barils par jour de réduction
donc ce qui provoque à l'effondrement
des prix parce que la réponse de l'opep
opep plus l'opep plus plus à du 13 avril
a été insuffisante
trop tard et en plus décalé pour une
décision de réductions au 1er mai alors
concrètement quelles vont être les
conséquences de cette chute de la
demande une baisse des prix c'est bien
cela la une baisse des prix
effectivement on est à moins de 30
dollars le baril à 27 28
aujourd'hui le baril américain est en
dessous de 10 9
donc on est dans des situations extrêmes
et chacun de prendre des dispositions
selon ces systèmes à politique
économique
donc les pays à structure de production
nationale comme l'arabie saoudite avec
aso diarra mco ou la russie avec donc
des sociétés comme rose nef ou lukoil et
bien peuvent réduire rapidement aux
etats unis une question de gestion du
marché offre demande donc la production
américaine a déjà baissé a à peu près de
7%
c'est insuffisant il faut suivre il ya
des mises en stock très importante
il ya encore de l'espace aux états unis
a pour la mise en stockage
mais là il ya une course contre la
montre alors outre la baisse des
importations le fait que l'aviation
civile soient cloués au sol
est-ce que c'est l'une des principales
explications à cette chute
comme je viens de vous l'expliquer à
quelques minutes tout plat application
transports tout l'utilisation transport
à des du pétrole est profondément
profondément touché et cela simplement
en quelques semaines n'est ce pas trois
quatre semaines ont suffi pour réduire à
pratiquement zéro les vols aériens sol
des vols fret continua à se poursuivre
et quelques destinations sont poursuivis
en termes de passagers
mais l'argument la baisse aérienne a été
un des éléments avec sur la suppression
des déplacements personnels et des
centaines de millions de voitures dans
le monde alors on parlait de ses prix un
très très très bas on sait que l'opep et
ses principaux partenaires se sont
accordés sur une baisse de la production
de l'ordre de 9 et avec 2 7 millions de
barils par jour en mai et en juin pour
c'est vous que cela va permettre
d'enrayer un peu la dégringolade des
prix non la décision a déjà été prise
prise n'est ce pas et les prix
continuent descente comme je viens de
bien il ya quelques minutes cette
décision était trop tardive insuffisante
et décalé a donc trop tardive parce que
on était parti de la situation du 6 mars
ou à l'opep plus n'avait pas obtenu
l'aval de la russie pour diminuer à
l'époque un petit peu la production de
l'ordre d'un million et demi de barils
pour couvrir la baisse de la seule
production la seule demande pardon la
seule demande chinoise
donc maintenant bien sûr on est passé du
ralentissement chinois a ralenti cement
mondiale et cela a pris du temps cinq à
six semaines pour repasser du sis à la
décision du 6 mars à la décision du 13
avril
cette fois ci comme vous l'avez dit il
s'agissait de réduire la demande de
pratiquement 10 millions de barils donc
on a perdu beaucoup de temps merci
beaucoup gérard fait ce père d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de recherche à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient